Iran is not interested in war Iran is
not interested in escalation of tension
in the region
I mean increasing the tension in the
region will not be in the interest of
nobody so Iran definitely would like to
to have peace establish in the
neighborhood and the first ingredient
for a peace in their in the region is
the removal of of the forces the
American forces from our region well the
position here is that Qasem Soleimani is
assassination is the price the United
States will have to pay for leaving this
region his death is the reason they have
to leave the troops that the Iranian
want the US troops to leave the entire
Middle East this is something they say
is not negotiable until that happens
this kind of rhetoric that back and
forth between the two sides will
continue and the tensions will continue
to increase as the other countries in
the region and in the world try to calm
the situation as much as they can
Doris a total trumpet talked about Iran
standing down in his White House address
last night but it seems that Iran
doesn't seem to be willing to give up
Qasem Soleimani x' work tell us war
we've been hearing from the man who has
replaced Qasem Soleimani at a memorial
service commemorating the late general
with the supreme leader this morning in
the capital we heard from Esmail Thani
who is now the head of the coast force
of the Revolutionary Guards he read a
statement that he had written for the
supreme leader thanking him for the
appointment to his position and
remembering him selamanya is a great man
he also said that in his new role and
nothing will change within the full
force of the Revolutionary Guards that
Qasem Soleimani is vision and work will
continue that he he himself is my Avani
will not veer off the path that possum
Soleimani put the horse forces on we've
also been hearing from a former head of
the Revolutionary Guard commander Major
General Rahim Safavieh who is now the
senior military advisor to the supreme
leader he said that the same ceremony's
assassination will bring about some
major security changes in the Middle
East he also accused the American spy
agency the Central Intelligence Agency
as well as Israel's spy agency Mossad
security agency Mossad for the
assassinations and he said that this the
Rockets that were launched in to Iraq at
the u.s. spaces there are there's just
the first step and it took the United
States 19 hours to respond and you
referred to u.s. president Donald Trump
as that stupid president who has
realized that they don't have the
strength to respond to Iran we've also
been hearing that the Iranian president
Hassan rouhani has been speaking to the
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
over the phone they just finished a
phone conversation in which the Iranian
president issued a very stern warning to
the British prime minister saying that
had it not been for hussam Soleimani
Londoners would not be enjoying the
safety and security that they currently
have he also urged the British
government to change their policy and
stand towards the assassination that's
occurred so there's a flurry of
diplomatic activity going on we've also
heard from the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau who has told the Canadian
foreign minister to send a diplomatic
team to
Terron to hold the talks with the
Iranian Foreign Minister Mohammad Javad
Zarif we're going to wait and see how
these diplomatic efforts will turn out
in trying to de-escalate the tensions
but at the moment various officials
inside Iran are adamant that the United
States is going to be held responsible
for the assassination of the late
general